[Applause]
why are the most venomous species
found in the warmest places on earth i
mean take australia for example
depending on who you ask it has all or
nearly all of the 10 most venomous
snakes in the world
plus the funnel web spider the blue
ringed octopus box jellyfish paralysis
tick and stone fish
all found in australia are the most
lethal of their kind
and even this cute platypus has an ankle
spur which in the mail
secretes a venom that can kill a dog in
humans it would merely cause
excruciating pain this question why do
the most
venomous species live in the warmest
places is one that i've wondered about
for most of my life
perhaps it's because i was born here in
the small town of taraugon australia
this is the first house where i ever
lived
as my mom recalls in the backyard there
was a shed
where we found red bucks and i used to
play in the show
i don't think once we found the red
backs that we let you in there
yeah that's very comforting thanks mom
now if you don't know what a red back is
it's a very poisonous spider hold up
i gotta tell past derek something you
see it's important that we say
venomous and not poisonous because
poisonous means
it'll be harmful if you eat it whereas
venomous means it'll try to eat you
and that will be harmful continue so
thankfully they never bit me otherwise i
wouldn't be standing here today
now before we go any further it's
probably worth asking is it true
do more venomous species really live in
hot places
well apparently i'm not the only one who
thinks so because i found this reddit
thread on the topic though it really
didn't explain
why that was the case but what about the
data well
here is a map of the global average
temperatures
compare that with this map that i've
colored in according to the number of
venomous species in each country
the country with the most venomous
species is mexico
with 80 different organisms with the
power to kill you
that's followed closely by brazil and
then australia
well this seems to all match up very
well with the global average
temperatures
so why is it so my first hypothesis was
that there's something about the heat
which enables the formation of these
venom molecules
so i ran that idea past professor
polyakov of periodic videos
no i don't think so all right because
the reason is
that if you go up a 10 degree centigrade
change in temperature round about room
temperature
will only double the rate of most
chemical reactions
and i don't think anything evolutionary
is likely to
evolve to such a big difference based on
just a factor of two in the rate
so maybe it's worth asking what are
these venom molecules exactly
well in most species where the venom is
delivered by fangs it has evolved from
saliva
in the funnel web spider for example the
lethal effect
seems quite accidental what you've got
to understand about the venom
it's there it's a secondary thing that
it actually kills
the actual reason that spiders have got
venom
is to digest their prey except they
happen to do most of it before they
actually eat it
injecting the venom and the venom will
start
to liquefy whatever they've caught
and once it's turned to liquid
all spiders live on soup the funnel web
evolved without any humans or other
primates around
and yet ironically its venom is most
potent for exactly this group
biggest evolutionary joke ever the
only group of animals with backbones
that's actually allergic to their venom
are the primates
we don't have primates in australia all
right
so it's lemurs monkeys apes
and us most species deliver not just one
type of venom molecule
but a whole cocktail of different
proteins that range in length from
short chain to very long chain molecules
and these molecules can serve a range of
functions some are neurotoxins which can
disable your nervous system
others are hemotoxins which actually
attack your blood cells and can dissolve
tissues
but since we're talking about cocktails
what would happen if you
drank some venom you could take a vial
of taipan venom and happily have it with
your scotch and it wouldn't be a problem
as long as you didn't have any
irritation on the mucosal lining or in
stomach ulcer or things like this it's
got to get into the bloodstream to be a
problem
okay so since drinking the venom is not
going to kill you
what should you do if you get bitten by
say an inland taipan
that's the world's most venomous land
snake what you do
don't panic stay calm i think that would
be easier said than done the venom
travels through the lymphatic system so
it doesn't usually travel through the
veins or the blood vessels so that's
just quite close under the skin
and if it reaches your nervous system
it'll shut down the signaling pathways
that keep your heart beating and your
lungs breathing
and so what actually kills you is
suffocation
so what you need to do is stay very
still and bandage up
the limb that's been bitten from the tip
all the way back to your torso
now the bandage needs to be really tight
to trap the venom within the lymphatic
system
but not so tight as to cut off the blood
flow to the limb
now once you've got it bandaged up you
need to find some anti-venom
what is anti-venom well it's made by
injecting a large
organism like a horse with a dilute
solution of the venom
the horse then produces antibodies for
that venom which you can harvest
and inject into yourself in case you get
bitten making anti-venom is tough work
it would take 70 milkings of a funnel
web spider
to get enough venom to make a single
dose of anti-venom
and what's worse anti-venom can only be
used on an individual a limited number
of times
because over those uses your body will
build up
antibodies to the anti-venom making the
anti-venom ineffective
so you might wonder well why can't you
just inject yourself with dilute amounts
of venom
and build up your own antibodies to the
venom that would work
except for the fact that when you get
bitten you need to have
a lot of antibodies in your system and
to keep your antibodies at that high
level
you would need to keep injecting
yourself with the venom say
every month and that's probably not the
best thing for you
but why is it that people in warm
climates need to worry about this
and not people in cold climates well i
went to the experts to find out about
this trend
you know broadly yeah there's really not
much of a pattern happening
really what about that reddit thread and
the map i made
if you're saying is there a global
pattern showing that you get more
venomous animals
in hot places i don't know if there is
in snakes which is the group that i'm
most familiar with in australia
the pattern is the diametric reverse of
that one
if you wander around southern australia
every snake you find on mount kosciuszko
is venomous
if you wander around the tropics of
darwin you're very unlikely to see a
venomous snake they're all pythons and
harmless collubrid snakes
now this is unexpected the most venomous
snakes in australia
live in the coldest places and the
reason for that is 20 million years ago
uh an itinerant sea snake coming down
from asia as australia drifted
up to asia got to australia it was
venomous to start with
there were no snakes in australia at the
time and so venomous snakes radiated
through australia
this big family called the alapati the
cobra family okay but on a global scale
my point remains
there are more venomous species in hot
countries there's going to be
vastly more venomous snakes in a warm
climate area than in a cold climate area
the problem is that there's vastly more
snakes so as a proportion
of the snakes that are there the
venomous guys are probably going to be
about the same
and maybe even less in the in the case
of a place like australia
than they would be in a cold area so why
are there more venomous species in warm
places
well the truth is there aren't at least
not as a proportion of species
the majority of venomous species on
earth are ectotherms
those are organisms whose body
temperatures are regulated by their
surroundings
now that means that they can only really
have short bursts of energy
so instead of chasing down prey and
running away from predators
they needed a different strategy to
allow them to survive
and so many of them evolved venom there
is a greater diversity of ectotherms in
warm climates so it only stands to
reason that there will be a greater
number of venomous species
but that's not to say that there aren't
venomous species in cold places
the only snakes that get into the arctic
circle are european vipers a venomous
species
but biodiversity alone isn't the
complete answer to this question
it also depends on evolutionary history
if you'd come to australia 20 million
years ago
there would have been no snakes at all
the venomous ones got here first and the
non-venomous came after
i think it's a really lousy explanation
but it's the best one that we've got
why is that a lousy explanation oh well
it
doesn't invoke any lovely complicated
piece of uh ecological theory or
anything else it's just relying on
history
but this is a pattern that's very strong
and doesn't seem to be explicable
any other way and nowadays in hawaii
there are no venomous snakes and the
same goes for jamaica
these are warm places that just haven't
evolved or have lost
any venomous snakes that they may have
had so it might just be
a lucky accident that we've been
fortunate enough to be blessed with a
few
venomous spiders i am also reminded that
we're living in a particular point in
time
roughly 15 000 years after the last ice
age
now that would have wiped a lot of the
ectotherms from the northern latitudes
of the northern hemisphere
for example in ireland there are no
snakes because the place was wiped clean
by an ice sheet
and snakes haven't managed to get back
to the island yet
my point is the distribution of species
depends on
what happened it may be an unsatisfying
explanation but
i'd rather know the truth than just
believe in a trend that's not
actually there
so what do you think is going to happen
to the spot on the screen as i narrow
the color of the blue morpho
is created by the structure of its
scales you see
as i started to go through this big
investigation
i realized just how complicated this is
and how many
mysteries are still out there for
example why are some species
deadly venomous and in others the venom
is pretty weak
and i didn't end up with anything
the deadly guys turn out to have
ecologies that are very similar to the
guys with very weak venom
and it may be an historical accident
another strange observation is that a
lot of snakes that have evolved more
recently
have actually lost the ability to
produce venom the big success story in
snakes worldwide are the harmless ones
they've actually evolved from venomous
snakes venom is an ancestral
characteristic
in modern snakes the successful snakes
are the ones that left it behind
and they gave it up and they're
proliferated despite not having venom
apparently the cost of making venom
isn't much more than the cost of making
saliva so it seems curious
that they would lose what seems to be a
killer advantage
over other species if you have thoughts
about this
or any other mysteries regarding the
global distribution of venomous species
put them in the comments below